Where are wounded society and where am it's dysfunctionality is now becoming a
parent,
you know,
through the political situations.
I mean,
I,
I am baffled by,
uh,
you know,
a government,
a president who basically likes to hurt people.
I mean,
that seems to be,
it.
It's this culture of cruelty,
cruelty that has been,
that has been created and,
uh,
well particularly if he feels slighted,
you know,
he wants to come back at you extra hard.
Yeah.
And it,
it's a reflection of probably of his childhood trauma.
I mean,
I think his father was very abusive.
Now he's,
it's his chance to get revenge,
you know?
And I mean,
he's the guy who,
Kim,
what's that?
When you love to take him for a trip?
Yeah.
You know,
I don't think it would do any good,
really.
I don't think it would do when they could.
Why not?
Cause I don't think there's a moral,
I don't think there's a core there.
You know,
my,
uh,
I mean,
I would certainly,
I don't think it would help him.
The Cure.
And Daryl,
I've worst work,
most with Said told me,
you know,
there are two kinds of people I will not give Iowasca too.
One is sociopath's and the other is schizophrenia.
Trump is a sociopath,
you know,
he has no interior.
He's never had a reflective moment in his life.
That's,
that's what concerns me.
It's all external.
You know,
he's like pure Id.
he is a a six year old,
an angry six year old.
If we met him at 16 would you have hope for his future or do you,
I mean when as a person beyond reproach or beyond help.
Like what,
what is the year?
So we have this idea in our minds that when a certain age is reached that a
person is just firmly established and there's no more growth.
Yeah.
You know,
you see someone who's a 60 year old fool that's a dying fool.
He's going to be a full till his last day on this planet.
Why is that though?
Why don't we just assume that someone lives a certain life,
has a certain amount of time here that the,
they're not going to learn.
Is it just because of our own past experiences with these types of people or are
we imposing a limitation on their growth?
I,
I'm very curious about that because we do do that.
We assume that if someone fucks up and they're 20,
we'll there,
they'll get better.
They'll,
they're going to evolve.
If they fuck up when they're 70,
were like,
that guy's a goner.
Well,
we make that assumption.
Yeah.
You know,
and it may not be true.
I mean,
it's not fair.
I don't think the way it's not fair.
Um,
I mean,
especially now what we're learning.
Um,
the other thing that psychedelics do that is kind of a new thing that we're
learning is neuroplasticity.
Yes.
It actually reorganizes connections in the brain.
You know,
siliciden does this and presumably the others,
the others do too.
Some of the [inaudible] means do it.
Um,
so that's a new thing.
You know,
you can actually change the,
the con activity of these systems.
That's probably not fair to say.
I mean,
my friend who came with me,
he,
he made a point when we were discussing this,
he says,
you know,
you shouldn't hate Trump.
You know,
he's used to that.
You should love Trump.
I said,
it's real hard for me to love Trump,
but,
but I think the point that he's making is that he is,
Trump is not the cause of it.
In some way.
He's the,
he's the symptom of,
of what's happening and he's,
he's the disruptor,
but the disruption is happening anyway.
And,
and so in some ways,
maybe we should be grateful to Trump because he's,
he's making,
you know,
he's,
he's making it so in everybody's face that,
that people are questioning everything and that's,
that's a good thing because the system,
it can't last,
you know,
so there's going to be a transition that's going to be pretty rough and Trump is
just part of that.
Not In any conscious way.
He's as much the victim of,
of the Times as anybody else.
And expectation that has,
the president has his finger on the nuclear button and a few other inconvenient
things.
Otherwise,
he would just be dismissed.
You know,
it was an old cranky old
guy.
The television,
he was fun before this,
I guess.
Yeah.
I mean,
before this he was your fired,
you know,
he was the,
the rich guy with his name on the big buildings.
Right.
He was a caricature,
you know,
he wasn't,
it wasn't what he is now.
What he is now is he's show,
he's exploited this vulnerability and the political system that we essentially a
popularity contest that choose our rulers.
And the idea of that,
and at first was to pick the best one based on public perception,
but that's not what it is anymore.
Now it's like we are so jaded as to how well this system works and as to what
significant and important about it.
And we just want our guy to win.
Now it's our guy and Hillary,
Hillary represented the bureaucrats.
She represented the red tape and the career politicians,
the one,
the proven liars,
the ones who were starting these Clinton foundations and making hundreds of
millions of dollars and giving these speeches and making hundreds of thousands
dollars talking to bankers but won't release any of the transcripts.
And Hey,
now if we got to drain the swamp and this guy was our guy to drain the swamp for
the people that voted for him,
you know,
and this is,
um,
and then he came on and it turns out he is,
the swamp is in escapable system is completely broken.
I don't think,
I mean I certainly don't think if we elected Hillary,
it would all be good.
It would still be a mass.
But,
uh,
but the problem with Trump is,
you know,
he's immune to facts for one thing and the I,
the man is obviously diluted,
possibly demented,
certainly a social path.
I mean,
and,
and very impulsive.
And this is not,
you need,
you know,
this is not the person you need to be leading the western world because,
because he's not reflective.
He's not.
It's all response.
You know,
this is,
this is the petulant six year old aspect of it.
He sees something and he reacts immediately.
There's no thought that intervenes and he's often said that about his business
deals.
He doesn't plan things.
He just goes on.
It's not that great a businessman.
If you look back on,
if you look at his business deals,
that's the same with this Korea thing.
I mean if he can pull that off,
more power to him but I'll bet you it's not going to go anywhere.
Cause you know Kim Jong noon and the Chinese who are behind it,
they are very smart and they,
they basically realized this guy is a buffoon and they will be able to make a
show on the world stage but they won't give up anything and people are already
saying this.
What did he actually come away with?
Nothing.
Some vague mumblings about denuclearization we've had that before.
Well it was unprecedented to see the leader of North Korea and South Korea meet
at the DMZ and shake hands and trap was traveled.
That was on precedent.
That was pretty fascinating.
That was pretty fast.
I think that's progress in some way and maybe his lunacy needs leads to
inadvertent progress or,
I mean maybe it's some sort of a,
I mean is people are many things he can't be entirely foolish.
There's probably a method to is Matt,
he never lost all of his money.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean he really has been at least marginally success.
Pretty early.
Success has gone bankrupt a few times.
But the point is that this is a guy that um,
he's probably pretty complex as much as he is crazy.
It's probably also pretty complex.
Some of that might benefit us because we have this fucked up system that's
undeniably fucked up.
It says right.
It's just a terrible idea though.
And it was an idea that was constructed,
you know,
in 1776 when it made sense back then it was the low,
a great solution to the problems of the times.
But we don't live in those times.
No,
we don't live in those times.
Equally complicated times.
And also we didn't have the media situation that we have now.
I mean this,
this is also part of the problem,
you know,
with the social media and everything,
it's true.
There's [inaudible] of fake news out there being produced on both.
You cannot tell.
So you've,
you've got the Trump,
uh,
you know,
reality distortion field,
right.
Which is reinforced by his really no pretense about ignoring what's real.
You know,
like this whole controversy about,
about the immigration and splitting up families will say,
well,
we're just enforcing the law,
but in fact,
you know,
at the stroke of a pen he could change that.
And we didn't enforce it that way before,
but so he's changed that,
you know,
it's just,
just change.
Just caved in and now he's,
yeah,
he just,
the families together supposedly nice.
It least that he's doing that like listening to public opinion and the outcry
has reached him and he's reacted.
Yeah,
but this is my car.
It's not that he cares about these children or a,
or,
you know,
how many people has he already traumatized as a result of this?
But yeah,
I'm glad he changed it,
but I'm sure that was a cynical decision.
Has Advisors said,
look,
Donald,
you know you're about to go to a,
if I have to go to a rally in Duluth,
I honestly think it's coming from,
those folks are not going to like this.
I think it's coming from his wife.
This is going around today.
This is a jacket she wore to a,
Oh,
what she say?
It says,
I really don't care.
Do you?
Yeah.
And this was to a meeting of day like immigration.
Kids.
The kids.
Yeah.
What is that?
Is that,
but is that some fashion jacket that she wore to that event?
What a stupid fucking thing to where I really don't care.
Do you?
Yeah,
I care.
I do care.
But what are we talking about?
What an bizarre open ended question.
I really don't care about what the tone deaf fitness of these people,
they have no sensitivity shoots.
How?
Look critic though of separating children from their families and she actually
made a surprise visit to the Mexican border today to check on it.
See what's going on.
Good for her.
Good.
Well,
she's an immigrant.
I mean,
this is the irony of the whole thing.
She barely speaks English.
The whole thing is so bizarre is that his own wife is a fucking immigrant.
I mean,
clearly the whole thing is crazy.
It's,
it's really strange.
But that jacket,
right?
This is what,
this is the sign of the simulation.
If you considered the simulation theory.
Yes.
Real might be real.
I mean,
sometimes I do wonder,
it's like,
it's like reality.
Whatever we choose to call it is becoming so weird.
I often ask myself,
who is writing this shit and can't they give me a better writer?